china is gone I'm induced in the last
years but seal America is bigger is
larger and you're just inner strength in
the American market in terms of economy
number fundamentals which is clearly
there and the inet was individual
population is the biggest in the world
why are you developing an SUV why not my
customers asking for it we have
conducted extensive research our
customers on three four five six girls
naturally gain support for you most of
them 11 SUV there in the carport for you
and they want to relate a bit beyond and
they ask as asking us for a long time
why you don't allow me to move up with
my SUV and 12 what I experience with my
two door convertible sedan Bentley
nursery so customers asking for it for a
long time so is the as-yet-unnamed SUV
going to be as important to Bentley as
the Cayenne is the portion
could you could sit volatility speaking
I mean we are much smaller as many
manufacturers as an for its part of our
realtor family were single family
relatively speaking SUV with a Lewis to
continue to sustain a very dominant
positions election market if Porsha can
sell 75,000 Kyon's in a year which it
did in 2012 how many 180,000 dollar
Bentley SUVs can you sell a meal plan is
over to sell 3000 cals a year on average
how long until Bentley sells a hybrid or
even an electric plugin we are working
on an eye bleach solution for a future
with a bit early to speak about it but
yes we are we are working on these
solutions to one needs to be pretty
wealthy to buy a Bentley this is not a
cheap car it's inequality good for your
business enough quality is it good for
your business the more wealthy people
there are surely that's good for Bentley
I mean of course of course but what is
the important is to maintain the older
homes in this changing world I net was
individually
believe the last number seen was 11
million people having more than 1
million cash immediately available to be
spent outside of real estate so that we
buy me work for battle is so people who
can access our cars are there the market
potential is there all is about
relevance and being comfortable toward
yourself in a way which is visible